i've robbed 12 banks in seven states
i have a little over nine million
dollars in cash
and no one knows who i am
bureau of investigation i want to turn
myself in i want to make a deal
what kind of deal i hand over all the
money i stole
in exchange for a reduced sentence it's
important
and what's so important about it i met a
woman
i want to be with her for the rest of my
life without lying about my past
[Music]
special agent hall this is special agent
evans where's the money
the man is telling the truth we can take
this money for ourselves
let's do it
whoa whoa i'm turning myself in fbi open
up
what exactly
his real name is thomas dolan former
marine demolitions expert
we needed to come clean i'm not a bank
robber anymore with the murder one
charge for killing one
of their own the feds will come after me
and keep coming
those two crooked cops are willing to
kill another agent
what are they capable of doing to you
and me
my girlfriend she had nothing to do with
this it's an evidence
i'm coming for you do what you have to
do
knowing how to blow stuff up that's uh
pretty cool
[Music]
evans i want to clear my name which
means i need a full confession from you
five four
three two
one
ready to confess
you